So, let's do the solution to our BTB &
BHT quiz. We have a BHT with 16 entries which
gives perfect predictions. We have a BTB with four
entries, gives us perfect predictions. The question was, how many
times do we access the BHT for each of
these instructions? We access the BHT in order to tell
us whether this instruction is a taken branch. We
do that every time we fetch an instruction. And because
we have a perfect prediction for both BHT and the
BTB that means that we will never fetch any instruction
that actually is not supposed to execute. So we now
just need to figure out how many times each of
these instructions execute. This instruction here initalizes R2 to 100
and that instructions executes only one time once we have
done executing it we will go into the loop, loop
here and then exit never coming back here. Same here.
This puts zero in R1. That executes only once. Now we have a loop. This loop
will execute as long as R1 and R2 are different. R1 initially has a zero
value, goes through here gets incremented, and then
we branch back. Now we execute this loop
once more, with R1 being equal to 1, and then 2, 3, et cetera. The last
iteration we do will be with R1 equal 99, and finally R1 will be incremented,
we jump back here. FInd out that R1 and R2 are now the same, because
RI is now 100 and exit the loop. So, there is 100 iterations of this
loop, and each of these instructions does
executes 100 times. This instruction here executes 100
times when we're staying in the loop, and once we, for the 100th time
jump back, it executes once more in order to exit the loop. So this instruction
executes for 101 times, and each time
any of these instructions execute, we're gong
to access the BHT to see whether those instruction is in taken branch or not.